director of the Chinese company john dandy
reforming sun yatsen
signed an agreement of understanding
[applause]
general director of ooo nakhodka
mineral fertilizer plant taras
semenovich donaga and chairman of the board of
directors of the chinese national chemist
engineering corporation before their fire
signed an agreement on the implementation of the
project of the nakhodka mineral
fertilizer plant general director of
biocad  dmitry valentinovich morozov and
chairman of the board of
shanghai investment holding georju did not
sign a shareholder agreement
[applause]
president chairman of the board of
mts alexey valerievich root from
vice chairman of the board of the
Chinese company huawei
kopin signed a memorandum of
understanding
[applause]
general director of the Russian
direct investment fund kiril aleksandrovich dmitriev
general director of mail.ru ooo boris olegovich
dobrodeev general director
of megafon
gevork  The Chairman of the Alibaba
Group, Jan Yong, signed
an agreement confirming their readiness to sign
binding documentation and launch a
partnership in the field of
Internet commerce in Russia and the CIS
[applause]
Chairman of the Board of OAO Sibur Holding
Dmitry Vladimirovich Konov and President of the
Chinese Silk Road Fund Wang Ya not
g signed  agreement on strengthening
cooperation Chairman of the Board of
PAO Sibur Holding Dmitry Vladimirovich
Konov and Chairman of the Board of Directors of the
Chinese petrochemical corporation
Sinopec
and Khaulin signed an agreement on the
main terms of cooperation in the
framework of the implementation of the Amur
Gas Chemical Complex project
[applause]
Chairman of the Board of PAO Novatek Leonid Viktorovich
Kapel  Gazprombank Andrey Egorovich Akimov
and the Chairman of the Board of Directors of the
Chinese Petrochemical Corporation
Sinopec
Yes and Howliang signed heretical
binding basic terms of the agreement on
the creation  and on the territory of the
People's Republic of China, a joint
venture for trading LNG and natural
gas in the domestic market of the People's Republic of China
[applause]
CEO of STV
Kirill Borisovich Filippov and
CEO of Media Corporation of Tea Media
Group
Shane Hoisin signed an agreement to
provide a platform for
television broadcasting
[Applause]
Rector  St. Petersburg
State University
Nikolay Mikhailovich Kropachev and Rector of
Tsinghua University Chu Yong signed a
cooperation agreement on the
implementation of a joint project
Russian Research
Institute at Tsinghua University [Applause] Aleksey Yevgenyevich Likhachev,
Director General of the State
Atomic Energy
Corporation Rosatom, and
Chairman of the Board of the Chinese
State Corporation  nuclear
industry her sean finn signed the
general contract for the construction of
units 3 and 4 ios
singapore
[applause]
executive secretary of the
pre  Igor Ivanovich Sechin, President of the Russian Federation for
the Strategy for the Development of the
Fuel and Energy Complex and
Environmental Safety,
and the Head of the
State Energy
Administration of the People's Republic of China,
Jang, signed the regulation on the
Russian Chinese Energy
Business Forum, Governor of the Tula
Region, Alexei Gennadievich Dyumin, and
Chairman of the Board of Directors, Great
Wall  motor you
gentium signed a cooperation agreement
for the implementation of the project the
second stage of the construction of a plant for the
production of cars of the havel brand in
the tula region
[applause] the
mayor of moscow sergey semenovich sobyanin and the
head of the state administration of
forestry and pastures of the
people's republic of china jan 7 moons signed a
memorandum of understanding on
cooperation in the field of conservation of
giant pandas
[applause]
Minister of Industry and Trade of the
Russian Federation day and dump
Yanovich Manturov President of the Republic
Tatarstan Rustam Nurgaliyevich Minnikhanov
and President of China's hair corporation
Joe U Yuntz signed a memorandum of
intent to implement an investment
project in the city of Naberezhnye
Chelny
[Applause]
Head of the Federal
Air Transport Agency Alexander
Vasilyevich Neradko
and Head of the Civil
Aviation Administration of the People's Republic of China in
Feng Janlynn
signed implementation procedures
agreement between the government of the
Russian Federation and the government of the
People's Republic of China on
improving flight safety, on
September 8, 2001, the Minister of
Economic Development of the Russian
Federation, Maxim Stanislavovich Oreshkin, the
Minister of Agriculture of the Russian
Federation, Dmitry Nikolaevich Patrushev, the
Minister of Commerce of the People's
Republic of
China, John Shan and the Minister of Agriculture
and Rural Affairs of China  People's
Republic of Hanfu signed a plan to
deepen cooperation between Russia
and China in the field of sui
[applause  s]
Minister of Economic Development of the
Russian Federation Maxim
Stanislavovich Oreshkin and Minister of
Commerce of the People's Republic of
China Jun Shai signed a memorandum of
understanding on stimulating the
development of bilateral trade
[applause]
Head of the Federal Service for
Veterinary and Phytosanitary Surveillance of the
Russian Federation Sergey Alekseevich
Dankvert and member of the State Council,
Minister of Foreign Affairs of China
People's Republic of China in Wang and signed a
protocol on its phytosanitary requirements
for certain types of crop
products
exported from Russia to China
[applause]
Minister of Agriculture of the Russian
Federation Dmitry Nikolayevich Patrushev and
member of the State Council, Minister of Foreign Affairs of the
People's Republic of China in Wang and
signed an agreement to
amend the protocol  on phytosanitary
requirements for wheat exported from the
Russian Federation to the
People's Republic of China dated November 1,
2017 Minister of Economic Development of
Russia  of the Russian Federation, Maxim
Stanislavovich Oreshkin and Member of the State Council
Minister of Foreign Affairs of the
People's Republic of China Wang and signed a
memorandum on the establishment of a
Russian-Chinese joint
scientific, technical and innovation
fund
[applause]
Deputy Prime Minister of the
Russian Federation
Minister of Finance of the Russian Federation
Anton Germanovich Silanov and member of the
State Council I am the Minister  Foreign Affairs of the
People's Republic of China Wang and
signed agreements between the
Government of the Russian Federation and the
Government of the People's
Republic of China on the settlement of payments
[applause]
President of the Russian Federation Vladimir
Vladimirovich Putin and Chairman of the
People's Republic of China Xi
Jinping sign a joint
statement of the Russian Federation of the
People's Republic of China developing
comprehensive partnership relations  and
strategic cooperation of those
entering a new era,
as well as a joint statement by the Russian
Federation and the Chinese People's
of the Republic on Strengthening Global
Strategic Stability in the
Modern Era
or
Koshak
Ladies and Gentlemen the
ceremony is over moving on to the
statement to the media of the
President of the Russian
Federation Vladimir Vladimirovich Putin
and Chairman of the People's
Republic of China Xi Jinping Dear
Chairman of the Seats Dear friend
Ladies and Gentlemen
sincerely pleased to welcome you to Russia
Chairman of the People's
Republic of China, Mr. sizing me, the
state visit of the Chairman of the People's Republic of China is
taking place in the year of an important anniversary of the
70th anniversary of the establishment of diplomatic
ties between our two countries, and I am
pleased to note that Russian-Chinese
relations
have reached an unprecedented high level.
This is truly a comprehensive
partnership and strategic
interaction. Mr. and I  We are
in close contact with Xi Jinping We regularly exchange
visits We communicate on the sidelines of international
events
Paying close attention to the
Russian  Chinese cooperation in
economic policy, humanitarian and other areas in the
course of the just-concluded
talks, we
discussed the state
and prospects of bilateral
cooperation in a businesslike and very constructive manner, examined
topical international problems in
detail, while paying close
attention to
Russian-Chinese cooperation in
those areas
that are really deep for us.
mutual interest,
and right now, when we were negotiating at the
table, we talked with colleagues and
noted that in each area we
really developed not only
measures for interaction mechanisms,
but specific
deep work is underway following the results, as we all
saw, a solid package of documents was signed,
I would especially note the joint statement  about the
development of relations of
comprehensive partnership and
strategic interaction
entering a new era in
which new large-scale tasks and
long-term guidelines are set, cooperation is
natural for  issues of economic cooperation were discussed in detail
China
firmly occupies the position of the leading foreign
trade partner of Russia
last year trade turnover increased by a quarter and reached a
record level of one hundred and eight billion
dollars there are noticeable successes and in the
investment sphere with the participation of
Chinese partners and Chinese
capital about 30 investment projects are being implemented
for a total  amount of 22 billion
dollars, with a significant part of these
funds invested in projects in the Far
East of Russia, you slept or a billion
Russia and China intend to develop the
practice of settlements in national
currencies  uninterrupted
banking services for transactions in the conditions of
instability in global markets
, cooperation in the energy sector has gained good momentum
russia is the leader in oil supplies to
china last year shipped 67
million tons  raw materials
, turbo steam will be put into operation in December, so for the
transportation of gas to the PRC along the eastern
so-called machine
max eastern route, negotiations are
underway on the possible export of fuel
in the western direction, and
mutual cooperation in the
field of production and marketing of liquefied
natural gas is being increased from the Russian Far East in  in November, a year ahead of
schedule, the third stage of the plant was launched and
there is little LNG, a significant share of which is
almost 30 percent 29.9 owned by the
Chinese side
;  agreements in the
field of peaceful atom a general
contract is concluded for the construction of 3 and 4 units of nuclear power plants
always a point with the participation of
rosatom construction of a
demonstration fast neutron reactor begins in china
In conjunction
with the visit of President Xi Jinping, the
opening of a plant in the Tula region
of a leading Chinese
automaker, the Great Wall Company, will be timed
to coincide with the opening of a plant in the Tula region using
advanced technologies
, 80,000 vehicles will be produced annually at the enterprise, and the
level of localization of production
will be 70 percent.
implementation of projects in aviation
helicopter construction in space exploration
biotechnology and pharmaceuticals in other
science-intensive industries it has been agreed to spend
years of Russian-Chinese
scientific, technical and innovative
cooperation
20 and 21 good prospects are opening up
in the field of
industrial production  with an investment of
10 billion rubles,
Russia and China aim to jointly develop
international transport corridors to
do this, to more actively use the potential of the
Trans-Siberian and Baikal-  the Amur
Mainline
and the Northern Sea Route the
joint border infrastructure is being expanded the
construction of a
new bridge and a road
bridge across the Amur River is being completed We attach particular importance
to strengthening direct ties between the
constituent entities of the Russian Federation and the
provinces of China
federal district and the provinces of the upper
and middle reaches of the Yangtze,
and today the chairman of the china and I
agreed to establish two more
formats of interregional cooperation
between the central federal districts of
russia and northern china, as well as between
our northwestern federal
district and the coastal provinces of the
southeast of the people's
republic of china  are of a
bilateral humanitarian nature
within the framework of a three-year
cooperation program in Russia and
China, cultural and film festivals
are held  important
youth sports exchanges and
mutual tourism is actively developing last
year, China hosted about 2.2 million
Russians, in turn,
more than 1.7 million citizens of the People's Republic of China visited
our country.
from the Moscow Kremlin to
another on the square,
most of the tourists from the
People's Republic of China can be
singled out to wave to them with pleasure,
I would like to
thank Mr. Jinping to all
Chinese colleagues for transferring
2 giant pandas to the Moscow Zoo, we
know that this is practically not such a practice
in China, this is a sign  special respect and
trust to russia to our specialists,
when we talk about the andes, a smile always
appears on our faces, so we accept this gift with
great respect and gratitude
, thank you very much,
these animals are the national
symbol of China, and we highly appreciate such a
gesture of friendship, and by the way, a little later, we
etc  The Chairman of the People's Republic of China
plans to visit the zoo and
look at these wonderful
animals while discussing topical
international and regional problems,
it was stated
that the views of Russia and China on most of them
coincide or are very close in
the joint statement we signed on
strengthening global strategic
stability in the modern era
, the principled position is emphasized
Russia and China on the unacceptability of
destruction of the existing systems of
agreements in the field of arms control,
disarmament and
non-proliferation, I
emphasize that our countries have coinciding
assessments of the situation around the
Korean Peninsula.
we cannot continue to
cooperate with Chinese partners
to reduce tensions on the peninsula and
strengthen security in
northeast asia as a whole
russia and  china working in favor of a peaceful
resolution of the crisis management in
syria advocating stabilization of the
situation venezuela remains
committed to the full implementation of the
joint comprehensive plan of
action on the iranian nuclear program
during the negotiations confirmed
intention to further enhance
cooperation between russia and china within the framework of the
un shanghai cooperation organization brix group20 from s and  on other leading
multilateral platforms, we will
continue our efforts to link
integration processes within the framework of the
Eurasian
Economic Community with the Chinese initiative of
the Silk Road Economic Belt in order to
create the prospect of a large
European partner, ladies and
gentlemen  joint work and
express confidence that the agreements reached
during the visit will serve to
further strengthen Russian
Chinese friendship will contribute to
to the prosperity of our countries and peoples, the
program of the visit of the chairman of the People's Republic of China
continues today we will speak at a
gala evening in honor of the 70th anniversary of the
establishment of diplomatic relations,
which will be held a big dead Chinese
leader as an honored guest will take
part in the St. Petersburg International
Economic Forum at the head of a solid
delegation of about a thousand representatives of the
state  and business, we will also
communicate with the heads of large
companies of the two countries who will hold 2
Russian-Chinese energy
business forums and it’s unpleasant to say about this the
rector of St. Petersburg University is
present, the ceremony of
awarding the chairman this day pinyon the
title of honorary doctor of
St. Petersburg State
University
thank you for your attention
[  applause]
tenten let it be there he says like
still little mama katya kassin
chill this dumb and gave nadia the topic
hard start show cd and
aunt skin farm in the sleigh eaten
armies and on operation  yu crowd
time then vadim thin
those miles you where bad and shinkoda
career you need a man putin sanchesa
you belly functions about the dress
paddington there shiva from here
pound yen a
good example of shimin ganse
swords to the end and then he think of
all the fun shot of it  to sean bean wai
city kung fu panda k'thun dorothy
what balls shanks annaite
ruby fabia fl further i'm too lazy jingle quant
m anchancha dresses on phase te en
and panin zunt mind sindo
diathesis to than 2 grubs
battle sancho oh covered figure whose
shadow is not one  I run a memorial service
to suppress and a tip
symbol from the blacks aga tula quanti then
further with their mistakes
me my tender fog and you coming undone
terrible things umbrellas and reading a
pinch the guy went to gold we now
headlights to the horde you wear this tea mental
season base and pulled positive angie
wallets  Sean Fontanka thrown into the jungle
taste
you up to further these pizzas in chemistry matai
shang liang learn and
show on single high potency
like that also and I always thought
to go
to  ntsov leave bengali me he tank tenth
in a row
sean by marriott dome and tea
in the queen size four
tire species she team mate us
all shungite come out
but me you and fan
kenzo step a very strong move for
chanel perfume amen amen amen amen and
dude want  she is stronger than the photo
walk wanna sing the hindu
tya departed a rare
outline helsing film from the ear root
hadish and here it is, the thicker the
chanson tian mother-in-law
city 3 county and I give you
that and those sanford who lived in the
room and yes and handles
so and I'm in bantan  sith is
wider and the essence of thousands of these in the middle
young avatar pictures gave away
drunk with grief phase humbucker
peter drink you fountain galyamin
angels like this sin bandera formation
go wrong and
platinum led by spirit and gave shushi
base to this I component
3d body rode to sit
then now
here  on him and his jetta pythagoras
i started to pull the guy senden
him to pull and having bought one lens
then then decide to stage the
army in anal
hard pull and hitman go cheap gave
hehe cylinder anton
then been high or g  Orba you fall them and
code file go there he he he did
he do what i want to think
in them at toby michaels report henschel
tour puddings .
here count to
teaming up 1 toon toon toon toon juicy
couture johnny
shadow so and I you and bustard
he gave juicy pear with anti
shank 2 ok then they want these there one
there there predators about big ben go
look apart from jobs jindo center
fun fun  city the dead [appl
use]